you're just looking at this sort of
melee surrounding Jerry Hutch as he
leaves Court a free man
it looked as though he was struggling to
find a way out but he has managed to
flag down a taxi now and is driving away
acquitted of the murder of kinahan gang
associate David Byrne who was shot dead
in that Infamous attack at the Regency
Hotel back in February 2016. this is the
end the so much chaotic end of a 52-day
trial the special Criminal Court the
building that you just saw Mr Hutch
emerged from a home of Ireland's
non-jury special Criminal Court he used
to try uh Gangland and terrorist cases
there's no juries so three judges the
lead judge Tara Burns was giving her
decision over the course of the last few
hours here and a lot of Doubt was shared
in that decision on the witness the key
States witness Jonathan dowdle a former
Shinn Fein counselor and an associate a
friend of Jerry Hutch he turned States
evidence and although he is now serving
time for a lesser offense he will now be
placed into Ireland's State protection
witness protection scheme but his
evidence was the key plank of the
state's k peace in this murder trial
against Jerry Hutch and during her
summation during the giving of evidence
the giving up the verdict here at the uh
special Criminal Court the judge cast a
great deal of skepticism on the evidence
given uh by Jonathan Daryl throughout
that trial and it was clear that they
said a great deal of skepticism was cast
Over the character of Jonathan dowdle
the key witness and therefore as she
came to the end of the verdict she found
Jerry Hutch not guilty of the murder of
David Byrne and it should be said I mean
you can probably get an idea just from
the scrum oh they've all gone from the
media scrum that has surrounded uh Mr
Hutch as he left the case this was a
murder that really did Rock Ireland to
its very core it was like something out
of a Hollywood Blockbuster you had a
SWAT team a fake SWAT team going into a
boxing weighing event in broad daylight
in a Dublin hotel opening fire with
AK-47s it was believed they were looking
for Daniel Kim and who has been named
Accord is the head of the notorious
kinahan cartel they didn't find Daniel
Cannon who was actually spoken of
escaping the hotel but they did manage
to find somebody who was a lieutenant a
member of the Canadian organization that
was David Byrne he was cornered in the
hotel lobby and shot six times with
Rands from the AK-47 as I said a case
that shocked Ireland it was a case that
escalated the burgeoning kinahan hutch
gang Feud and it turned part of this
city the inner city here in Dublin into
an absolute war zone 18 young men were
dead by the time the murders petered out
by around 2019
in October last year this trial which
was billed as Ireland's trial of the
century in some circles got underway 52
days of evidence but the upshot of all
of that is just in the last few minutes
the judge has acquitted Jerry Hutch of
murder and as you just saw there he
walked free from this course